on croyait que la pandémie avec elle le
ralentissement de l'activité humaine
avait permis de relâcher un peu l'énorme
pression qui pèse sur le climat mondial
mais on avait tout faux
il dit
l'organisation météorologique mondiale
parvient à la conclusion que peu importe
l'angle sous lequel on observe le
problème le résultat est identique
gaz à effet de serre niveau des mers
température des océans acidification des
eaux
tous les indicateurs clefs sont dans le
rouge et les conséquences de notre
inaction sont déjà sous nos yeux entre
autres les records de chaleur qui
affligent présentement l'europe et
l'asie sans compter les problèmes moins
visibles
écosystèmes associés
geeks tanguy certains des écarts
observés sont impressionnants par
exemple le niveau des océans alimentés
par la fonte des glaces augmente deux
fois plus vite aujourd'hui qu'il ya
trente ans on constate aussi que les
aussi un continue se réchauffer en
profondeur jusqu'à 2000 mètres ce qui va
provoquer des changements de courant
irréversible durant des siècles
la solution évidemment passe par la
diminution radicale des gaz à effet de
serre le développement de technologies
propres et leur partage avec les pays
moins riches
hommes rappelons que les sept dernières
années ont été les plus chaudes jamais
enregistrées depuis l'ère industrielle
ce normal grondin radio canada montréal